I am Iron Man
and you know Robert Downey jr. you see
him he's I think here I'm coming up the
road there he is take a look at this
what's he doing he's prepared for the
role there he is
you know they say the entrance is one of
the most important things for a
character
this stuff just feels to me like this is
the this is like the fantastic summer
camp I never went to
[Music]
[Applause]
that's because I think what the audience
really responded to last time was it was
a film that was safe to bring your kids
to see but was actually engaging enough
intellectually for adults and and nerds
like me and other people to really feel
like there was a some real storytelling
there who are you
first of all he looks like Thor second
wha he acts spectacularly what you will
see very soon in a theater near you
every few months there will be a movie
featuring Thor
[Music]
the first time I put on the suit I was
terrified it was it was you know it just
was real that this was going to be
something that I may be doing for a very
long time
the kind of amazing thing is what
happened with Avengers and how well it
was received and this kind of very
ambitious genre picture essentially we
brought all these different superheroes
together and we were wondering why did
we jump the shark and the audience was
like no we like it and so we thought the
only way to continue winning so to speak
is to is to make it much more kind of
Tony is back to kind of hardware mode
and doing this sort of stuff he was
doing earlier on in the series hey wanna
have a rousing discussion about truth
honor patriotism
what I tried to make his kind of
spiritual complexity even darker and and
more damaged but also he's the god of
mischief so I've made sure that he has a
really good time
can you give me your best death stare is
that it
[Laughter]
that was a really cute death stare that
was it yeah a cat
how do we know the good guys from the
bad guys if the shooting at you they're
bad
so you are the Falcon yes and I mean
tell me what's what's it like being a
superhero is everything I thought it
would be is I kept my character's name
is Sam Wilson and you know he's more of
a military operative than he is a
superhero
he teams up with Captain America and
goes and fights crime it's all very
surreal I mean I've never done anything
like this you can see the set that one
this is crazy I don't think I've ever
even done a movie that cost as much as
maybe just this set does
[Music]
it's amazing I mean I we were both fans
of the films of the Marvel movies so
it's kind of crazy to be in one you
definitely do this and the question is
whether you want to get some momentum
and shrink on the movie I mean I have
never experienced anything quite like
this yeah in just about every way
[Music]
what do we do can we fight of this group
it was a competition every day oh gosh
the goofiest I was I mean Maki not funny
over the top
it's like Matty Evans bet me yeah yeah
yeah I think Maki
I think goofiest would probably be bad
yeah but you know every time you the
loudest yeah don't put it and we got a
lot of big personalities like minor
isn't cure like now but yeah he's he's
so low-key is he really no he's not no
way open it's incredibly trippy and and
and funny and weird but also really
moving when he's sort of floating in the
beauty in the vastness of it or near the
end before he's thrown back into the
reality of his limited body and mind
before the training begins I just found
that incredibly moving
[Music]
my voice is a little messed up from
having to scream in a very high place or
the Avengers what are you guys doing
here wait be more handsome in person oh
I didn't get a phone cool I found out on
Instagram someone's just Marvel just
posted for the world to see and I feel
like I was the first one to find out and
then Kevin rang me up I was like I've
got great news
you're gonna be spider-man so much has
happened since I last saw you lost my
hammer like yesterday so that's still
pretty fresh no keep Loki's alive can
you believe it he's like he's up there
okay there's a wackiness to it as there
is to these sets and and and and the
general story I think they might pick
that one this whole marble days is like
it doesn't make any sense like you know
that you're walking around in a dream
wasp is the legacy character she's right
there on the cover of Avengers number
one finally every single character from
that first issue of Avengers is here on
the big screen are you kicking butt in
this in this movie I am although it's a
team effort I have three sons in it you
have three stuff it's ridiculous it
feels like overkill but is it four
different we all work simultaneously
I'm not what you think I am
the first time I put on I was like oh my
gosh I'm a Disneyland character this is
crazy okay now tell also you gonna make
them let you take this honestly it
smells so bad I'm not sure I want it
gone for the head I don't feel so good
you're alright I don't know I don't know
what's happening I don't want to go
don't want to go
[Music]
we literally left it all on the field on
this one it's a huge chunk of my life
and the experiences I've had the
friendships I've made mean a lot to me
and to here you know you're wrapped on
the last movie just it it shook me up
[Music]
[Music]